Dave: Good morning, Hank and John.
I'm Dave. I’m the operations manager at DFTBA.
This is the rest of our staff.
This is Caenaan, the warehouse manager.
Caenaan is the reason we now have a forklift
in the warehouse.
What’s the name of the forklift?
Caenaan: Well, of course, it’s Forky McForkface.
Dave: This is Rachel.
She’s our head of creator support.
She gets to deal with all our wonderful creators
on a daily basis.
She’s helped design many of our products.
And this is Meg, our head of customer service.
Any time you get an email, it’s probably
coming from Meg.
So the real reason we’re here today is to
introduce you to the person who created Pizzamas.
This is Valerie Barr.
Say hello.
Valerie: Hello.
Dave: Valerie actually lives here in Missoula.
She works for VidCon, but her claim to fame
in life, and really this is her lasting legacy,
is she designed Pizza John.
Valerie: You’re welcome.
Dave: So there is a long and storied back
history to the creation of Pizza John, which
led to Pizzamas.
Hank actually did a video last year where
he explained the backstory, right?
Valerie: Yes.
Dave: And that link is down below, but give
us the ten-second version of Pizza John.
Valerie: Well, John likes pizza.
One time in a video, John had a mustache.
Thus, all of this.
Dave: And here we are, six years later.
We created kind of our own Pizzamas museum
here, and we’re gonna have Valerie take
us on a tour through the illustrious history
of Pizzamas.
You ready to start?
Valerie: Yup.
Dave: Let’s do it.
Valerie: ‘Kay.
2010. Pizza John. The Original. Well loved. Well worn. Classic.
Meg: 2012
Dave: Green Pizza John
Valerie: Neon nineties Pizza John
Caenaan: Eyes eyes eyes eyes eyes eyes Pizza
John
Rachel: Vampire Pizza John
Meg: Evil Pizza John
Caenaan: 2013.
Just the hoodie.
Valerie: 2014
Rachel: Bowie Pizza John
Meg: Glowy Pizza John
Caenaan: Halftone Pizza John
Valerie: Obey Pizza John
Rachel: 2015
Caenaan: Warhol John
Meg: Rainbow Pizza John, our first charity
shirt
Valerie: Blue neon Pizza John
Caenaan: Pisa John
Rachel: Misfits Pizza John
Dave: Faux knitted Pizza John sweatshirt
Rachel: Nebula John
Valerie: This year, as Hank talked about on
Monday, we asked our favorite designers to
design shirts, and Rachel is going to tell
you about that.
Rachel: So this year we had a few different
artists.This one was designed by Judy Kaufmann.
This one was designed by Sara Cervantes.
The one right above me was Julia Pott.
We have this one right here, which I did.
We have Big John Pizzeria, designed by TEKST.
We have Ming Doyle, which designed this pretty
sweet indigo one right here.
And then we have the design duo Rude that
designed this one right here.
Dave: Rachel, I hear there’s a few more
items in the 2016 Pizzamas collection.
Rachel: Why yes there are, Dave.
Dave: Are those pajama pants you’re wearing?
Rachel: They are.
They are called the PJ-PJ.
Dave: And are they soft?
Rachel: They’re very soft.
As Hank also talked about Monday, we will
have the personal pizza Pizzamas box, which
will contain quite a lot of things that you
can only get in the box.
It’ll have this hot and fresh shirt, a hot
and fresh notepad, a Pizza John pizza cutter
with a bottle opener, an apron with gold imprints,
and of course, the box.
So just like last year, we wanted to have
an item that donated its proceeds to charity.
This year we have the Pizza John pet leash.
If you purchase this pet leash, 100% of its
profits will be going to the Animal Legal Defense Fund.
If you have any questions about the Fund,
definitely go to the link down below.
Wait a minute, what’s that?
Dave: This is a DFTBA sock that is only available
for purchase through the DFTBA Awesome Sox Club.
This is the November sock, designed by Rachel.
And Rachel, how many are left?
Caenaan: 500
Dave: That’s right, 500 more subscriptions
are left, so buy them soon. They're awesome.
So thanks for joining us on this tour of the
Pizzamas museum here at the DFTBA warehouse.
We’ll let the professionals take it from
here.
Caenaan: Forky McForkface wants to remind
you: Don’t forget to be awesome.
And John, we’ll see you tomorrow.